it's great to be on television this is
fantastic I'm a big fan of the product I
love HGTV that is my jam right there
home yeah home and garden television
that is watch it all the time however I
feel like that channel is biased toward
home owners every show that is for the
homeowner flip my house fix my house
where is the show for the renter yes
that's what I want to see I want to see
a show called get my security deposit
back that's too sketchy contractors
showing up we're just gonna patch a lot
of holes we're patching a lot of holes
figure out what that popcorn smells
coming from today I get my security
deposit back I I am big I'm broke I do
rent I rent I don't have any money one
way I like to combat being broke is I
like to eat at continental breakfasts at
hotels I'm not staying at yes you can
you can just do that if anybody want you
guys want free breakfast tomorrow yeah
it's the easiest thing in the world I'll
tell you how to do it just get up before
9 o'clock go over like a hampton inn
make a waffle yeah they can't stop you
you think they're gonna stop you let me
tell you something no front desk
employee making nine bucks an hour has
the balls to accuse you of that
ridiculous crime they don't have the
stones for I wish they would say
something to me and this what I thought
it like a dozen times in my life I'm
cocky at this point I'm on national
television calling my shot stop me so
I'm the John Dillinger of breakfast
stealing they can't say something to me
because I have the best defense in the
world have you ever accused me of that
I'm just gonna act incredulous it's like
what's that
okay let me get this straight you're
under the impression that I got up this
morning
got in my car drove to your stupid
little hood oh I'm sorry
picked up my fiancee bro stupid little
hotel started eating all the eggs and
the bacon and the sausage on this peanut
butter and jelly sandwich I have saran
wrap back here what is that my lunch I'm
gonna get you free meals out of this
they would fall over themselves
apologizing to you
yet that's literally what I do step
first step every Valentine's Day that's
how I knock it out I call it brunch she
instagrams the whole thing makes her
friends jealous now actually I just got
married I don't have a fiancé anymore I
just got married thank you we don't have
any kids
but I do think one of the most beautiful
things you're going to see in the world
is a parent reading to their young child
right what's better than that now
there's no quicker way to take that
moment from Hallmark to hilarious than
seeing the parent mispronounce words
from the children's book have you ever
seen that before that will make your
afternoon I saw a friend of mine one
time and she was like and then the ball
ricochetted off the walls like no no
nothing ricochetted actually uh can you
say something there are you allowed to
make a comment I don't know is there a
number I can call anonymously to prevent
SAT disasters from happening it reminded
me of a few years ago I was in Boston
with my dad we were walking through the
park
they had their boss in common they have
all these duck statues and he sees them
and he stops he goes oh my god Andrew
these are the ducklings from that book
it's like what book it's like make way
for ducklings that story used to read
you every night before you went to bed
it's like I don't remember that I it's
like yes you couldn't sleep I read you
the story about the Ducks you begged for
it every night it's like I have no idea
what you're talking about and that's my
point if you guys out there take
anything away from this set please just
remember reading to your children
is a waste of time they won't know
they're not going to remember in fact
the only thing you might do is pass down
your miss pronunciations of words and
trust me do not want that weighing on
your conscience
it's a terrible thank you very much
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography